[موسيقى]
الغى الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي قرار المجلس
العسكري الذي اعتبر مجلس الشعب منحلا
وادعاه الاستئناف جلساته لحين انتخاب
برلمان جديد من جانبه اعلن المجلس العسكري
عقد اجتماع عاجل لبحث تداعيات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القرار
[موسيقى]
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين ما هي الظروف التي اتخذ فيها هذا
القرار وكيف يقرا مع فتوى عدم دستوريه
انتخاب البرلمان وما هي تداعيات السياسيه
والقانونيه التي يمكن ان تترتب عن اتخاذه
في هذا
[موسيقى]
التوقيت قبل ان يكمل ايامه العشر الاولى
في السلطه فجر الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي ما
راه الكثيرون مفاجاه غير متوقع على الاقل
في التوقيت الحالي فقد اصدر الرجل قرارا
اعاد بموجبه برلمانا حله قبل اقل من شهر
المجلس العسكري الذي استند في قراره ذاك
الى فتوى من المحكمه الدستوريه قضت ببطلان
انتخابات البرلمان واعتبرته بالتالي في
حكم ما لم يكن
اصلا بدايه رئاسه قويه ام بدايه ازمه
كانما الايام القليله التي مرت عليه رئيسا
لمصر قضاها محمد مرسي في التفكير عما ينقل
اليه سلطه فعليه لا
بروتوكوليا ربما لذلك عجل بالغاء قرار حل
مجلس الشعب المب واعادته الى قبه البرلمان
مره اخرى الى حين انتخاب برلمان جديد لا
ناص هنا من التساؤل عما اذا كان القرار
موجها الى المحكمه الدستوريه العليا التي
قضت بعدم دستوريه القانون المنظم للعمليه
الانتخابيه التي افرزت مجلس الشعب ام
تراها مواجهه مبكره مع المجلس العسكري
الذي اتبع قرار الدستوريه بقرار حل
المجلس وفي كل الاحوال فان خطوه مرسي التي
تبدو سياسيه في المقام الاول تشكل مدخل
جدل قانوني فالى ما رمى مرسي وهل قراره
صحيح من الناحيه
الدستوريه معارض قراره يصورونه مخالفا لكل
القواعد القانونيه والدستوريه المعمول بها
كما انه هدر لاحكام القضاء ستكون له
برايهم اثار سالبه على مجريات الحياه
السياسيه في البلاد
وبس ما يبدا به رئيس الجمهوريه فتره حكمه
كما
يقولون ليس التفافا على قرار المحكمه
الدستوريه وليس نيلا من سياده القضاء يقول
متفهمون لخطوه الرئيس المصري ينبه اصحاب
هذا الراي الى ان محمد مرسي رئيس مكبل
اليدين يقف على رمال متحركه فلا دستور ولا
برلمان في البلاد ولا صلاحيات لرئيس
الدوله الا ما ارتضى له المجلس العسكري
بحكم اعلانه الدستوري المكمل وفي المقابل
يعلق من انتخب الرجل امالا عظاما عليه
يرقب الشعب ايامه المئه الاولى في الرئاسه
وتنتظر قوى سياسيه وثوريه كما يعتقد ثمنا
سياسيا لدعمهم له في جوله الحسم
الرئاسيه في ظروف كهذه ربما راى مستشار
مرسي من القانونيين ان احكام المحكمه
الدستوريه تقريريه لا اكثر وان رئيس
الجمهوريه وحده من يختص بحل البرلمان وقد
تشكل عوده البرلمان المنتخب الذي يغلب
عليه اللون الاسلامي توازنا في القوه كما
قد يستقوي به الرئيس في وضع الدستور
واستعاده السلطه التشريعيه من المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه فهل ينتهي بذلك دور
المجلس
العسكري ومناقشه هذا الموضوع
معنا من القاهره صبحي صالح وكيل اللجنه
التشريعيه في مجلس الشعب المصري والقيادي
في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ومن القاهره
ايضا ينضم الينا رمضان بطيخ استاذ القانون
الدستوري في جامعه عين شمس وعبر الهاتف
معنا اللواء الدكتور احمد عبد الحليم عضو
المجلس المصري للشؤون الخارجيه اهلا
بضيوفي وابدا معك استاذ صبحي صالح بدايه
ضعنا في اجواء الظروف التي اتخذ على اثرها
هذا
القرار نعم الظروف السياسيه التي حتمت
تدخل الرئيس ان هناك ازمه دستوريه حقيقيه
في البلاد السلطه التشريعيه المنتخبه حلت
على خلاف مقتضى الاجراء القانوني وهناك
منازعه قضائيه حول هذا القرار وهناك حاله
بلبله في الراي العام وكان يتعين على
الرئيس ان يتدخل لانه نحن لا نفهم ما هو
الاساس الدستوري ان يتولى المجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه سلطه التشريع في البلاد
رغم انه سلم سلطته رسميا بانتخاب رئيس
للدوله ادى اليمين وكان يتعين ان تكون
السلطه التشريعيه بين المجلس المنتخب وبين
رئيس الدوله اما حل المجلس مجلس الشعب وهو
مجلس منتخب بقرار اداري فهذا الكلام مخالف
للقانون مما استوجب على الرئيس ان يتدخل
بصفته حكم من بين السلطات ليملا الفراغ
الدستوري ويعيد لحكم المحكمه الدستوريه
حجته بالطريقه القانونيه الصحيحه في هذا
قراءات لكن سؤالي ابسط من ذلك في الحقيقه
سالت عن عن الاجواء مع من جلس الرئيس محمد
مرسي من استشار قبل ان يعلن هذا
القرار هو الدكتور مرسي رئيس الجمهوريه
بيستش تقريبا كل الجهات وبيست عين بكل
المستشارين من كل التوجهات وبالتالي هو
كون رايه بعد استطلاع اكثر من جهه متعدده
المشارب والتوجهات السياسيه واطمان لسلامه
موقفه الدستوري
والقانوني طيب استاذ رمضان بطيخ مرسي رئيس
مرسي كان اعلن في احد خطبه التي تلات تعلن
فوزه
بحضور نواب مجلس الشعب المنحل الى ان
المجلس سيعود الى الانعقاد
بالنسبه اليه انذاك يعني المساله كانت
تحصيل حاصل ومساله وقت لا
اكثر بالنسبه لما صدر عن الرئيس المنتخب
الدكتور محمد مرسي اليوم من قرار
بعوده المجلس هو اولا قرار بسحب قرار الحل
يعني اصدر المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
حينما صدر حكم المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
ببطلان القواعد القانونيه التي انتخب على
اساسها البرلمان اصدر المجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه قرارا بحل البرلمان حينما
تولى رئيس الجمهوريه الدكتور محمد مرسي
رئاسه الدوله وبتاريخ اليوم اصدر قرارا
بسحب هذا القرار الصادر عن المجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه وهذا حق له ان يصدر قرار
بسحب قرار الحل خاصه اننا في اطار
المواعيد القانونيه فلم يتحصن هذا القرار
بعد ومن ثم فمن حقه ان يصدر قرارا بسحب
قرار الحل
السابق ومن ثم تثور المشكله الان البرلمان
حينما
عود كما دعى الرئيس الدوله فمن هي السلطه
التشريعيه الحقيقيه في البلاد في ظل وجود
اعلان دستوري
مكمل ينص على ان المجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه هو صاحب السلطه التشريعيه فيضان
اذا سمحت لي سنصل الى هذه النقطه المهمه
جدا لاحقا لكن نتوقف قليلا اكثر مع الظروف
التي احاطت بهذا القرار اتوجه هنا الى
الدكتور احمد عبد الحليم هل تعتقد ان
المجلس العسكري كان على علم بهذه الخطوه
مسبقا او تشير بشكل ما لا اعتقد طبعا ان
المجد العسكري كان على اي نوع من العلم
بهذا القرار الذي فوجئنا به
جميعا والدليل على ذلك ان بمجرد صدور هذا
القرار اعلن المجلس الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
اجتماعا طارئا لبحث هذا الامر فاذا هو
فوجئ ونحن فوجئنا جميعا بهذا الموضوع لكن
خليني اقول طبعا انا مش قانوني لكن ستشير
براي المستشار فاروق سلطان الذي عقب على
قرار محمد مرشي بعوده البرلمان وقال ان
هذا القرار باطل 100% وان قرار عوده
البرلمان لا يستم الى اي شرعيه قانونيه او
دستوريه
ومخالف للقانون والاعلان الدستوري الصادر
من قبل المجلس الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه الاولا الذي قضى بحل مجلس الشعب
ليس القرار الاداري الذي صدر من المجلس
الاعلى ولكنها المحكمه الدستوريه العليا
والان كان موجود الرجل الذي تولى صياغه
هذا الموضوع وقال ان والله حتى المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا سوف تعقد اجتماعا
للجمعيه العموميه للمحكمه غدا لبحث هذا
الامر الذي يعتبر مخالفا لكل الاعراف وكل
الذي كان متوقعا من الرئيس الذي كنا نتمنى
ان يفصل تماما بين السلطه التشريعيه
والسلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه القضائيه هذا
القرار حيه كان فيه اعتداء على السلطه
القضائيه على المحكمه الاداريه العليا
التي حولت الموضوع اصلا الى المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا ثم المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا التي قضت ب
بطلان هذا المجلس ثم كان القرار العسكري
الذي صدر من المجلس هو قرار تنفيذي وليس
اكثر يعني ليس هو القرار بحل المجلس ولكنه
القرار الذي ينفذ حكم المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا على اي حال يعني احنا في ازمه
قضائيه وازمه دستوريه وقبل هذا وذاك نحن
في ازمه امنيه لان لا نعلم ما الذي سوف
يحدث غدا في هذا الموضوع لكن خليني اقول
حته على كل هناك هناك دعوه الاجتماع ربما
المجلس العسكري اجتمع في هذه اللحظات ايضا
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا تجتمع لكن اعود
الى الاستاذ
رمضان
بطيخ يعني في مقابل القراءه القانونيه
التي تجيز للرئيس ممارسه صلاحياته بحل
البرلمان او اعادته الى الالتئام بعد حله
هناك حق دقيقه اخرى ايضا في مواجهه هذه
القراءه وهي
ان البرلمان حل عندما كان الرئيس الان هو
رئيس مرسي كان مرشح فقط
يعني القرار سابق لكون مرسي اصبح رئيسا هل
يمكن مع ذلك ان يتخذ قرار من هذا
القبيل نعم نعم حتى وان كان قرار الحل قد
صدر اثناء ان كان الرئيس محمد مرسي
مرشحا ثم تولى رئاسه الدوله الان فمن حقه
ان يتخذ قرارا بسحب قرار الحل خاصه اننا
في اطار المدد القانونيه لسحب القرارات
الاداريه فهذا قرار اداري صادر عن المجلس
الاعلى باعتباره رئيسا للجمهوريه ومن ثم
فالرئيس محمد مرسي باعتباره رئيس
للجمهوريه وهو سلطه موازيه للسلطه الاولى
من حقه ان يتخذ قرارا بسحب القرار الاول
ولكن بهذا القرار يصبح في مصر سلطتان
تشريعيه تشريعيين المجلس العسكري شدد مره
اخرى على انه هو من يمتلك السلطه
التشريعيه الان هل يستقيم
الامر هذه هي الاشكاليه كيف حلها ذلك ان
الاعلان الدستوري نعم الاعلان الدستوري
المكمل ينص صراحه على
ان السلطه التشريعيه في يد المجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه ومن ثم فعو البرلمان دون
ان نناقش مدى دستوريه هذه
العوده
في اطار الحكم الصادر من المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا سيصبح لدينا سلطتان
تشريع تان في اطار الاعلان الدستوري
المكمل المجلس الاعلى هو السلطه الاصيله
والمجلس المنحل ليس هو السلطه الاصيله
فالحل من وجهه نظري ان الرئيس محمد مرسي
وهو يملك ذلك ان يتخذ قرارا بالغاء
الدستور الاعلان الدستور المكمل اذا اتخذ
هذا القرار يستقيم الامر اما اذا لم يتخذ
هذا القرار ب الغاء الاعلان الدستوري
المكمل سنصبح امام اشكاليه دستوريه في
وجود سلطتين تشريعيين في البلاد سلطه
تشريعيه نسميها فعليه وهي المجلس الذي عاد
بعد حله والسلطه الدستوريه وهي المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه طبقا للاعلان
الدستوري المكمل اذا القرار الان في طور
الجدل القانوني والدستوري لكن اي تداعيات
يمكن ان تترتب عن الغاء الرئيس المصري
قرار حل البرلمان نناقش ذلك بعد فاصل
القصير ارجو ان تبقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من من جديد مشاهدينا في
حلقتنا التي تبحث دلالات قرار الرئيس
المصري بالغاء حل البرلمان والتداعيات
المحتمله لهذا القرار استاذ صبحي
صالح يعني
الازدواجيه الازمه التي يخلقها هذا القرار
ب وجود راسين انصح التعبير لسلطه تشريعيه
واحده الراس الاول عند المجلس العسكري
الثاني عند البرلمان الذي تقرر اعادته مره
اخرى كيف يمكن حل هذا
المازق حل هذا المازق انا اولا اتفق مع كل
ما قاله الاستاذ الدكتور رمضان لكنني
اختلف معه في هذه الجزئيه فقط المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه يتولى اداره شؤون
البلاد بصفه مؤقته وفق النص الماده 61 من
الاعلان الدستوري ثانيا المجلس الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه يتولى سلطه التشريع
استثناء وفق الماده 56 مقرر من الاعلان
الدستوري مجلس الشعب يتولى سلطه التشريع
اصلا وفق الماده 33 من اعلان الدستوري
وبالتالي عندما يتعارض النص يقدم الخاص
على العام ويقدم الاصل على الاستثناء
وبالتالي اذا كان مجلس الشعب موجود تنتفي
سلطه المجلس الاعلى في التشريع لانها
استثناء على الاصل فاذا جاء الاصل انتفى
الاستثناء وبالتالي صدور القرار الرئيس
الجمهوريه بسحب القرار كان هناك قرار بحل
المجلس رئيس الجمهوريه بما له من سلطات
مقرره سحب هذا القرار خلال المعاد
القانوني فازال العقبه التي تحول دون
اختصاص المجلس الاصلي باختصاصه الاصيل
وبالتالي يكتسب المجلس اختصاصه بقوه
القانون وبدون تفكير على الاطلاق لانه نفي
النفي اثبات الذي احال التشريع للمجلس
العسكري كان غياب المجلس فاذا هذا المجلس
انتفت عله المجلس العسكري في التشريع
مساله بديهيه جدا خاصه اذا علمنا ان
المجلس العسكري ليس له صفه اصلا في اداره
شؤون البلاد لانه تم انتخاب رئيس وهناك
مؤسسات شرعيه منتخبه من الشعب وفق الاعلان
الدستوري انتهت مهمته ثانيا لا يوجد اي
اصل ولا معنى ولا مبرر ان يمارس المجلس
الاع للقوات المسلحه تشريع سلطه التشريع
في البلاد رغم انه سلم السلطه اذا اعمال
النص اولى من اهماله يبقى الاصل اذا جاء
الاصل غاب الاستثناء واذا غاب الاصل جاء
الاستثناء طيب دعني ارى راي الدكتور احمد
عبد الحليم
اعمال الراي افضل من او النص افضل من
اعماله
واذا عاد المجلس المجلس
التشريعي انتفت سلطه المجلس العسكري هل
تقرا الامور بنظرك بهذا الشكل ايضا اقول
لحضرتك بوضوح شديد جدا
الاتجاهات القانونيه كثيره جدا والخبراء
الذين يقولون انهم خبراء في الدستور
كثيرين ومتعددي الاتجاهات والايديولوجيات
والى اخره فما نسمعه من احد نسمع ضده من
اخرين ولكن خليني اقول لك بمنتهى الوضوح
واصرح ليس هناك شيء الان اسمه مجلس الشعب
حكم المحكمه الدستوريه بيشمل حل مجلس
الشعب بالكامل بسبب بطلان بعض مواد قانون
مجلس الشعب ومخالفتها الاعلان الدستوري
والاعلان الدستوري المكمل واضح في هذا
الكلام بيقول ان والله بعد الانتخابات
تسلم السلطه التنفيذيه الى رئيس الجمهوريه
ثم تشكل لجنه صياغه الدستور وان تنتهي هذه
اللجنه من هذه الصياغه بنهايه شهر سبتمبر
ثم في خلال شهرين بعد ان يطرح الدستور
الجديد لمده 15 يوم على الشعب للاستف يتم
انتخاب مجلس الشعب الجديد في ما بعد ذلك
في خلال شهر اكتوبر ونوفمبر ولكن خليني
اقول لحضرتك حاجه برض انبه بيه ان ما تم
الان من هذا القرار الذي اتخذه رئيس
الجمهوريه الذي ليس له سلطه اصدار مثل هذا
القرار هو مبادره مسبقه قبل ان يعرض
الموضوع الخاص بمجلس الشورى على المحكمه
الدستوريه التي ينتظر ايضا ان تقوم بحل
مجلس الشورى لانه قام على نفس العوار الذي
ق عليه مجلس الشعب فليس هناك شيء اسمه
مجلس الشعب يعني لا نفرض شيء غير موجود
وهننت هنشوف المجلس الاعلى القوات المسلحه
هيقول ايه وهنشوف
الجمع
الدستوريه في الانتظار استاذ
رمضان يعني اذا ما رفض المجلس العسكري
القرار ورفضته ايضا المحكمه الدستوريه
العليا من هي الجهه الاخرى المخوله ل البت
في هذه
المساله هو الحقيقه
ا المحكمه الدستوريه العليا اصدرت حكمها
وانتهى الامر بالنسبه لها الان نحن في طي
اعمال تداعيات هذا الحكم اعمال تداعيات
هذا الحكم بدا بقرار من المجلس الاعلى بحل
البرلمان وثم جاء رئيس الجمهوريه الان
الدكتور محمد مرسي بسحب هذا القرار ف عدنا
الى المربع رقم واحد من الذي يتولى تنفيذ
حكم المحكمه الدستوريه العليا لان الحكم
يحتاج الى اليه في التنفيذ كما ذكرنا من
قبل مرارا وتكرارا هذه الاليه ليس لها
وجود في الاعلان الدستوري ومن ثم فليس
امامنا الا الانتظار لحين اعداد الدستور
والنص فيه على اليه تنفيذ احكام المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا ا استاذ صبحي
صالح يعني الرئيس مرسي لم يكمل حتى مؤسسات
الرئاسه سؤال يعني لماذا
الاستعجال نعم استعجال خلق ازمه في
الحقيقه لا لم يخلق ازمه اولا الرئيس رئيس
الجمهوريه غير ملزم باستشاره جهات والا
سيكون الرئيس تحت الوص صايه هذا كلام غير
مقبول من حيث الشكل الرئيس لا يستشير احد
الا مستشارين لكن يخبر مؤسسه انه بصدد
اصدار قرار ده نوع من فرض الوصايه
والاستئذان لكن دعيني اتكلم
اولا الاخ الاستاذ الدكتور احمد عبد
الحليم مع احترامي وتقديري بيقول الرئيس
لا يملك اصدار هذا القرار ما المجلس
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه عندما اصدر قرار
الحل كان قد اصدر هذا القرار بصفته يؤدي
قائم باعمال رئيس الجمهوريه فلما جاء
دكتور مرسي فاصبح رئيس الجمهوريه الفعلي
فالذي يملك اصدار القرار يملك سحبه ثانيا
لا يوجد شيء اسمه مجلس الشعب لا في شيء
اسمه مجلس الشعب في نظريه اسمها نظريه
الوجود القانوني ولذلك لما المحكمه
الدستوريه العليا سنه 84 وفي سنه 87 ات
حكما بعدم دستوريه المجل مؤسسه ام بالنواب
الذين هم فيه نعم انا انا انا انا بدي
مثال حتى تكون المساله واضحه المحكمه
الدستوريه في واقعتين سابقتين وليست وقعه
واحده لما حكمت بحل مجلس الشعب وبطلانه
رئيس الجمهوريه استفتى الشعب على قرار
الحل لان نظريه الوجود القانوني اهمالها
يساوي فراغ مؤسسه دستوريه المجلس الاعلى
لما طلع قرار بحل مجلس الشعب لم يدعوا
الناس للانتخاب مجلس بديل ولم يدعوا الناس
للاستفتاء وبالتالي الغى مؤسسه دستوريه
وسلطه من سلطات الدوله هذا كلام بشع
للغايه لا دستوري ولا حتى سياسي رئيس
الجمهوريه صحح الوضع نفذ حكم المحكمه
الدستوريه تنفيذا صحيحا وكاملا لانه في
الماده الثانيه دعا الى انتخاب مجلس جديد
خلال 60 يوم بعد اعتماد الدستور على النحو
الذي يختاره الشعب لنفسه وبالتالي قرار
رئيس الجمهوريه حافظ على مؤسسات الدوله
واحترم حجيه الاحكام وامر بتنفيذ الاخرى
خلال 6 يوم المتعدده فقد اختم مع معك
براي الاستاذ رمضان الذي قال انه في
الحقيقه هذا القرار هو استباق لقرار اخر
بحل مجلس
الشورى يعني ازمه اخرى
جديده مصر تدخلها سياسيا وقانونيا
ستنجا بالتاكيد مع
عرض ما عرض عدم دستوريه مجلس الشورى على
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا سيجد سوف يتخذ
ذات المسار وسوف ينتهي الامر الى بطلان
تشكيل مجلس الشورى لانه قائم على ذات
المواد التي قضي او حكم من قبل بعدم
دستوريتها فهذا امر محتوم بالنسبه لمجلس
الشورى وسوف ندخل في اطار نزاع دستوريا
جديد الا اذا كان الدستور قد صدر واظهر
كيفيه التعامل مع احكام المحكمه الدستوريه
ل رمضان بطي استاذ القانون الدستوري في
جامعه عين شمس واشكر ايضا صبحي صالح وكيل
اللجنه التشريعيه في مجلس الشعب المصري
والقيادي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين واشكر
الخبير العسكري اللواء الدكتور احمد عبد
الحليم كنتم معنا جميعا من القاهره بهذا
تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
نلتقي باذن الله في قراءه جديده فيما وراء
خبر جديد تحيه لكم
و
[موسيقى]
ه